[Musique]
le groupe est moins connue aujourd'hui
mais sans compte en plus tard ange est
toujours là bonsoir mélanie pockets à la
formation de rock français entame une
tournée de deux ans pour son
anniversaire elle s'arrête à la batterie
de guyancourt et oui et le groupe a même
sorti un nouvel album en 2010 huit
heureux c'est sous titres et c'est le
quarante quatrième album du groupe
alors bien sûr les membres se sont
renouvelées avec les années mais il y en
a un qui est toujours là
christian décamps 72 ans l'un des
fondateurs est le chanteur du groupe
alors en 1969 ans j'ai créé connaît la
gloire dans les années soixante dix il a
fait notamment la première partie de
johnny hallyday en 72 il joue au
mythique festival de reading en 1973 et
le même jour que genesis le groupe de
peter gabriel
imaginez grégory alors les années 70 66
disque d'or récit d'un million d'albums
vendus anges c'est du rock progressif
[Musique]
alors pour les nostalgiques ou les
novices anges c'est ce vendredi 22
février à la batterie de guyancourt une
bonne occasion d'écouter la voix si
caractéristique de christian décamps que
mon bien de l'entendre
aujourd'hui il est accompagné de son
fils tristan qui résident ou benoît case
où il est né et hassan hajjaj merci
mélanie poquet que l'on retrouvera la
présentation du 7-8 culture